قنبله من العيار الثقيل القتها المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه في الحلبه السياسي فقط
جنائيه من تولي اي منصب وزاري
حكومه السادسه
الاسرائيلي واختيارته
اما بنيامين نتنياهو فسارع الى مقر اقامتي
اهم شركاء حكومته لتطيب خاطره والاتفاق
معه على كيفيه الرد بينما التفا كبار
اسرائيل قيادتنا
قرار المحكمه يملي على نتنياهو اقاله درع
من منصبه الوزاري ان لم يقدم استقالته من
تلقاء نفسه في مقبل الايام والا فسيعتبر
ذلك تحقيرا لاعلى سلطه قضائيه في اسرائيل
وقد حذر زعيم المعارضه من تداعيات عدم
تنحدرعي على اسس الديمقراطيسيه
فهي غير شرعيه ولا يمكنها ان تطلب من
الشعب احترام القانون اذا لم يقل درعي
فانا اسرائيل ستواجه ازمه الدستوريه غير
مسبوقه ولم تكون دوله ديمقراطيه او دوله
قانون
لكن القرار قد يعجلوا سعي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الموصوفه بالاشد التطرفا الى
تقليص صلاحيات المحكمه العليا في الغاء
القوانين وفي تسييس لجنه تعيين القضاه وهي
اجراءات يخرج الاف الاسرائيليين للاحتجاج
عليها باعتبار انها ستقود نظام الحكم في
اسرائيل وستنهي مبدا الفصل بين السلطات
وسط تصيب الديمقراطيه في مقتل قرار
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه لا يبقي مكانا
للشك في ان لا احد فوق القانون من وجهه
نظرها سواء كان وزيرا او رئيسا للوزراء
لكنه سيفتح الباب على مصراعيه على صدام
غير مصبوق بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والقضائيه في اسرائيل